morning everyone good afternoon
today i'm joined by minister
minister
minister
and minister
doctors tam and you are also joining us
virtually for two years now the kovit 19
pandemic has dominated our daily lives
here in canada and around the world
however today we find ourselves in a
much better position than we were in
march 2020.
we know a lot more about corvid 19.
we have safe effective vaccines and a
highly vaccinated population
we have testing and surveillance tools
that allow us to identify people who are
infected and to track the trajectory of
the virus
and we have new treatments that can help
keep some patients from getting
seriously ill
in addition after two years of following
individual public health measures such
as getting vaccinated wearing masks
keeping our distance and staying at home
if sick canadians know what to do to
keep themselves and each other safe
we see this playing out right now as
jurisdictions across the country are
adopting and adapting their public
health measures and restrictions in
alignment with their respective
circumstances
as we know recent data indicates we have
passed the peak of the latest wave
driven by the omicron variant
as provinces and territories adjust
their public health measures it is time
to adjust our approach
this is possible because we have now
multiple tools at our disposal to help
us with this transition
and to do it as safely as possible
these tools include a strong
surveillance system a highly vaccinated
population continued access to vaccines
access to therapeutics both in and
outside our hospital system and
increasing access to rapid tests
today i'm announcing that we are easing
our border measures
these changes are possible not only
because we have passed the peak of
omicron but because canadians across the
country have listened to the science and
to experts followed the public health
measures and taken steps to protect
themselves their families and their
communities
as of february 28 therefore the
following border measures will be in
place
first we will be returning to the random
testing surveillance program for all
vaccinated travelers that was in place
before omicron came in
this means that fully vaccinated
travelers arriving to canada from any
country in the world will only need to
take a pcr covey 19 test if they are
randomly selected
further
and perhaps more most
importantly fully vaccinated travelers
who are selected under the mandatory
randomized testing regime will no longer
be required to quarantine while awaiting
test results
second
as a parent myself i know that kids have
been in fact impacted severely in in
many ways in the last two years
and that's why i'm glad to announce that
we are lifting restrictions for children
less than 12 years old of age who are
not yet fully vaccinated
and traveling with fully vaccinated
adults
this means they will no longer need to
wait and self-isolate before attending
school daycare or day camps
they will also no longer be subject to
testing and other specific requirements
unvaccinated travelers however will
continue to be required to be tested on
arrival
on the 8 and quarantine for 14 days
third
travelers will now have the option of
using either a negative corvid 19 rapid
antigen test or
a molecular pcr test to meet pre-entry
requirements
to be valid the corvid 19 antigen test
must be authorized by the country the
country in which it was purchased and
must be administered by a laboratory
healthcare entity or
telehealth service
travelers who choose to present a valid
negative rapid antigen test will have to
take the test no more than 24 hours
before their schedule flight or arrival
at the land border
for those choosing to take a molecular
pcr test the rules don't change it has
to be taken no less than 72 hours prior
to to prove a previous corvid 19
infection the government of canada will
continue to only accept the molecular
test results taken at least 10 calendar
days and no more than 180 calendar days
before entering canada
finally the government of canada will
adjust the travel health notice from a
level 3 to a level two
that means that the government will no
longer recommend that canadians avoid
all travel for non-essential purposes
i want to underscore that canadians
should still exercise caution when
traveling abroad
there is still the real risk of becoming
sick or stranded while abroad and having
to extend
their trip or find themselves in need of
medical assistance should be test
positive for kobe 19 while traveling
abroad
travelers should also understand that
there is a continued risk that border
and travel measures in other countries
as well as in canada may change while
they are abroad
the border measures i have just outlined
are transitionary or transitory measures
not permanent ones we will be
reassessing them in the following weeks
and months it's important to note that
if the epidemiological situation
continues to improve if hospitalizations
continue to diminish and if canadian
canadians continue to get their booster
shots further easing of travel
restrictions could be considered in the
coming weeks
this means that again if the situation
warrants
the testing exemption for short trips
under 72 hours for instance could be
reinstated and eventually further
testing requirements could be dropped
french for my fellow francophone
citizens
today
because we made the right choices as
canadians
but also because we have
overcome the peak
virus and we've followed public health
measures and taken precautions to
protect ourselves our families and our
communities
as of the 28th of february
changes to the border measures will be
the following
first we are moving away from testing a
hundred percent of travelers coming from
other countries than the usa
so
and they will be selected randomly
instead
moreover and this is perhaps the major
change being announced today
fully vaccinated travelers who are
selected for this mandatory randomized
testing
my kids have been impacted many ways in
the last two years
and that is why i'm glad to announce
that we are lifting restrictions for
children under 12 years of age who are
not yet fully vaccinated and traveling
with fully vaccinated adults
travelers will now have the option of
using a negative covert 19 rapid antigen
test or a molecular test
must be authorized by the country in
which it was purchased
and must be administered by a laboratory
healthcare entity or television
travelers who choose to present are
valid negative rapid antigen tests
will have to take the test no more than
one calendar day before their scheduled
flight or arrival at the land border
covert 19 infection the government of
canada will continue to only accept
molecular test results taken at least 10
calendar days
and no more than 180 calendar days
before entering canada
this means that the government will no
longer recommend that canadians avoid
travel for non-essential purposes
i want to stress
canadians
should still exercise
when traveling abroad
as well as in canada
may
in the following weeks and months
situation
and hospital hospitalization levels
continue to drop
the canadians continue in great numbers
to get their booster shots other easing
may be considered
for example if only if the situation
permits
the exemption for testing of trips for
under 64 hours
may be put back in place or
canadians i'm happy to announce these
changes today as i know many of us are
looking forward to living with fewer
restrictions
however we must continue to exercise
prudence
let me be clear our fight against the
virus is not over
as we have seen over the last
two years kovit 19 does not follow a
predictable path
it does not abide by any timelines
canada needs to be prepared to
face future waves future variants which
may or may not be smaller than the
current omicron surge depending on how
the virus continues to evolve
today's announcement is obviously very
encouraging but i will repeat it all
measures are subject to constant
re-evaluation
we will continue to adjust them
according to science
prudence and the evolution of the
epidemiological situation
i would like to thank canadians
everywhere for doing their part getting
vaccinated including boosters and
following public health advice from
their local officials
our actions are part of the reason we're
able to transition to this phase of the
pandemic a phase where we are beginning
to learn with the virus
it's obvious but it's important to
remember
we have individually and collectively
the power to reduce the impact of the
virus on our daily lives
living with kobe 19 means that we must
exercise this power and make smart and
safe choices for our communities
and ourselves thank you and i will now
turn it over to minister gabra
thank you very much minister duklow uh
bonjour hello everyone
i want to begin by acknowledging that
i'm uh joining you along with my
colleagues today from the traditional
territory of the algonquin and
anishinaabe peoples
today is a great day for canadian
travelers tourism and aviation
this is great news the slow set we've
always said that we will adjust our
border measures based on public health
recommendations
and this is what we are doing today
as a next step i am happy to announce
good news that i know many communities
across the country have been waiting for
currently
only 18 canadian airports can receive
international flights
as of february 28th the ban on
international flights to all remaining
airports that normally receive
international flights
will be lifted
in upcoming months
other airports
will also receive international flights
great news for communities like windsor
london fort mcmurray mountain and many
others
by receiving international flights this
will support local tourism create good
jobs and grow our economy
these airports will work with transport
canada the public health agency of
canada and the canada border services
agency to put in place measures to start
safely accepting international flights
in the coming weeks and months
i also want to take a moment to talk
about cruises since this season will
start soon
i know how important the cruise season
is to the tourism industry in many
communities like victoria and quebec
city
this is why i can assure you
that we will have more to say very soon
about how testing for cruise ship
travelers arriving at canadian ports
will work
in time for the cruise ship season this
spring
in conclusion
i want to thank our airlines
airports
tourism operators and workers for their
tireless work
over the past two years
pilots ground crews cabin crew
air traffic controllers and many others
have kept travel safe
have kept goods moving and have kept our
economic recovery on track
and
mercy
a big thank you the measures we're
announcing today are possible thanks to
canadians who have stepped up rolled up
their sleeves and gotten vaccinated
merci thank you and now i'll pass it on
to my friend mr medicine
merci
good afternoon everyone thank omar as
well for
acknowledging that we are on indigenous
territories of the algonquin people
since the onset of this pandemic our
government has implemented reasonable
and prudent measures at our borders
as the pandemic has evolved
so has our response
always guided by the best science and
evidence available to us
19 has reached its peak in canada as
provinces and territories
amend their health measures
we need to move to the next phase of the
pandemic and adopt a more sustainable
approach and for the long term
any further i would like to take a
moment to thank the members of canada
border services agencies for their
ongoing tireless work
they are literally canada's front line
at our borders and as minister of public
safety i'm proud of
their efforts which they undertake every
single day under some of the most
extenuating and challenging
circumstances
canadians will recall that
this pandemic began in march 2020 when
we had to rapidly implement a series of
new measures to protect against a virus
that many of us were just learning about
at airports and border crossings across
canada people rose to the occasion
since then cbsa officers have been
responsible for enforcing a wide variety
of public health measures which have
changed with
on the health situation here in canada
and around the world
and today is another moment of change
over this time the canada border
services agency has been responsible for
implementing provisions across the
country
and i'd like to remind all travellers
even if you are vaccinated you must
continue to use arrived continue to use
arrive can
we puberty
you can use the mobile application or
the website
to provide mandatory information
in the 62
or 72 hours before your arrival to
canada is possible thanks to three big
things
canada's world-leading vaccination rate
decreasing hospitalizations rates and
effective tools like rapid tests
therapeutics and treatments
but more than anything else it's because
of the ongoing sacrifices and collective
effort that canadians are making and i
want to thank all of them for the role
that they are continuing to play in
making today's announcement possible
your efforts are helping to protect not
only yourselves and your neighbors
you're helping us all get through this
together
i'd like to thank canadians
for having gotten vaccinated and for
respecting
health
scientific data in order to put in place
our border measures commitment to you is
that we will never hesitate to do what
is necessary to keep people safe and
before i turn it over to uh my colleague
minister vwasano i'd like to provide a
few words by way of an update
on the ongoing concrete actions that the
federal government is taking to end the
illegal blockades across the country
following the declaration of the
emergencies act yesterday
there has been significant progress made
to secure our borders
in british columbia
thanks to the rcmp
and following a series of arrests and
seizures
we have now seen that the pacific
highway border crossing in surrey
is reopened
similarly in kutz alberta
yesterday the rcmp carried out a number
of highly sophisticated and coordinated
arrests and seizures
leading to the seizures of
a significant number of deadly firearms
we have now seen again in conjunction
with the cbsa and the local law
enforcement the reopening of the couts
port of entry
the day before yesterday
we saw that again following a highly
coordinated law enforcement operation
undertaken by the windsor police service
the ontario provincial police
and with the assistance of the rcmp
a number of arrests that took place
in windsor which allowed us to reopen
the ambassador bridge
where roughly one quarter
of all commercial trade takes place
on a daily basis
while we have seen progress
it is important that we continue to
secure that progress going forward
i want to take a moment to address the
situation here
in ottawa
and i want to acknowledge the
resignation of chief slowly
now of course
this is not a decision that is within
the remit or the mandate of the federal
government
our focus
is to ensure that the ottawa police
service
as well as the opp and the rcmp have all
of the tools
that are necessary to restore public
order
in ottawa
i want to take a moment to highlight
that an integrated command center has
now been set up so that the rcmp and the
opp
can share and assume command and control
over the enforcement operations which
will be necessary to bring about public
safety on the streets of ottawa again
i would be remiss if i didn't take a
moment as well
to point out the tremendous degree of
sacrifice that uh those who live in
ottawa have had to endure
and as i said yesterday this is not
trivial we're not just talking about
interruptions when it comes to people
dropping off their kids at school or
getting to work
or moving about
what we have seen in ottawa is an
ongoing and sustained effort
by a small organization
who with a very extreme ideology
has
intimidated harassed and has broken the
law in a way that is unacceptable
the state of the situation on wellington
street over the course of the weekend
is unacceptable and we have seen it now
for three three weekends in a row
and it must stop
and this is why we're going to continue
to ensure that law enforcement has every
single piece of equipment every
personnel
and everything that they need at their
disposal
it also explains why it is that the
government took the careful and
deliberate decision yesterday to invoke
the emergencies act and i want to update
canadians that today
we have now published the declaration of
the emergencies act which will enable
the government to quickly operationalize
and bring to life the words which appear
in that declaration
that includes declaring certain zones as
being prohibited for assembly where
there may be a risk to the breach of
peace as we have seen here in ottawa and
elsewhere
and this will be a concrete tool to
bring clarity uh to those that are
continuing to participate in the illegal
blockades that it is time to go home we
will also be sure that through the
emergencies act
that
law enforcement have all the tools that
they need be it tow trucks be it
barriers and other assets and equipment
so that we can crowd control and ensure
that the flow of trade and traffic flows
very smoothly on a daily basis and here
i'm thinking particularly about
communities like windsor and kutz and
where other ports of entry um facilitate
the trade and commerce that is so
critical to our economy
and finally
we are taking concrete steps to give
banks and financial institutions the
tools that they need to put a stop
to put a stop to the flow of any funds
proceeds through conventional currency
or cryptocurrency that may aid and abet
the illegal blockades
and i'm assured by conversations that
i've had with the commissioner of the
rcmp and other representatives of law
enforcement that they understand the
urgency of the situation so that all of
these tools can be put to their disposal
as quickly as possible
this has been a long three weeks and
people
are
in desperate need of reassurance
and especially those who live here in
ottawa
and everything that the government has
done
has been with the focus on protecting
the health and safety of canadians and
we are going to continue to work around
the clock until we get that job done and
we obviously depend on our law
enforcement to now enforce the laws that
the government has written
with that i will turn it over to my
colleague minister wassino messi
well thanks very much uh minister
minichino uh bonaparte mon good
afternoon everyone i too would like to
acknowledge that we are on the unseated
territories of the algonquin and snobby
peoples and let me just begin by
thanking
minister meducino and minister leblanc
for your steadfast collaboration and
work with officials in alberta and
making sure that we're able to do what
needs to be done to open up the traffic
at the coots border uh as minister for
alberta i thank you for your
collaboration and your steadfast
cooperation with the authorities in
alberta on behalf of albertans and
canadians so thank you both very much um
minister claude mercier
as all canadians have done throughout
the pandemic for being the voice of uh
people that want to travel again and the
airports that have been closed
necessarily uh but today is a new day um
as i've mentioned colleagues on a number
of occasions
it's safety first and then travel
safety first
then travel today's announcement is an
important step on our pathway of a safe
and prudent reopening if this is a
gradual process that puts science and
evidence at the center of our decision
making
and i want to be clear with canadians
travel is safe yet risk remains
a complete lifting of restrictions at
this time
isn't good for canadians or for canadian
businesses
we don't want to have to snap back
restrictions but we are prepared to do
so if need be
a gradual process provides
us with predictability provides the
the industry with predictability and
helps everyone keep moving in one
direction which helps everyone
i look forward to meeting in person
safely with tourism businesses and
organizations across the country the
work that you do
is what makes canada such a wonderful
place to explore announcements like the
one we are here making today help ensure
that canada
continues to be recognized as a
destination of choice
coupled with our high vaccination rates
and focused on health and safety
canada has a huge marketing advantage as
one of the safest places in the world to
travel to and today's announcement is an
important step in signaling that
canada's visitor economy is opening up
welcoming travelers for an all-important
summer season
to everyone in the tourism sector
let me say this
whether you be worker
owner operator
we know how long you've waited for this
day
we know how hard it has been
and we have had your backs
and we will continue to have your backs
and brighter days are ahead
of
me to all those folks from this tourism
sector business owners operators we know
how long you've waited for this day and
how
throughout the entire pandemic we'll
continue to have your backs as long as
is necessary
i am pleased that once again
international travels will be able to
make memories in a safe destination and
make the most of all that our beautiful
nation has to offer thank you thank you
i'll turn back to the moderator
thank you okay
we have a few questions in the room so i
believe first we have sebastian de lossy
radio canada and then uh tony mccharl's
toronto star after that thank you
merci uh
thank you my question is from mr
minister although all ministers are
invited to respond yesterday you invoked
the emergencies act
which is a stick of sorts today with the
lifting of these border restrictions
that's kind of the carrot isn't it
have you given in
to the blockaders demands and have those
demonstrators in some way influenced
your decision-making response thank you
very much for your question let me
respond
in two ways
[Music]
which has evolved over the past weeks
and months and since
the omicron variant came into play
in december so we have exercised
prudence we have based our decisions on
science
and on sound epidemiological
decisions
in the same breath i'd say we have to
exercise prudence
today's announcement
does not change
anything when it comes to the government
of canada's approach
to vaccination
these measures that i've announced today
affects vaccinated canadians
the conditions under which they can
travel have indeed been relaxed for
unvaccinated individuals nothing changes
the best protection available when you
travel domestically or abroad is getting
vaccinated
thank you
follow-up
there's the emergencies act which will
enable you to seize and to use tow
trucks minister mentino referred to this
this would be to clear trucks out of the
way what are you going to do if the tow
trucks do not want to take part in these
operations
some have already announced that
intention what is your last resort
um as the prime minister and minister
medellino and others have explained the
invoking of the emergencies act is to
provide additional tools to law
enforcement agencies and communities who
want to end the illegal blockades and to
protect our critical infrastructure to
protect our economy
one of those tools is to ensure that
tow truck operators are compelled to
offer services to end these illegal
blockades
so the you know obviously our
hope is that tow truck
operators
are able to comply uh
with
with the requirements that law
enforcement agencies the good news is
that so far we've cleared three
blockades without having to utilize
these measures so that is ultimately our
hope but these are additional tools if
needed and uh will deal with with the
with the
hypothetical scenario if someone refuses
the order law enforcement agencies will
enforce the law
um this question i think is for mr
mendentino uh minister
i didn't hear you uh thank the ottawa
police chief and a lot of residents here
are wondering who is in charge and
you've referenced opp and rcmp now
controlling the management of the
situation
i'd like to know what's your expectation
as to how they're going to
manage the situation and end the
blockade here
especially when there are already
premiers and civil libertarians saying
you have not met the threshold to
trigger this act
well just first with regards to uh chief
slowly um you know i acknowledge that
this is an individual who has served
many years uh on the front lines of the
public service
has uh crashed through many uh barriers
uh in uh rising to the position of being
a chief of police and i think that there
is an important uh reflection there um
and as to the decision itself as i uh
pointed out tonda that is not something
that the federal government has
any um jurisdictional insight into there
are uh mechanisms that uh that exist
there uh within the um the windsor
police board but what i will say
is what i what i will say yes i'm sorry
i said i meant the ottawa police board
thank you
what i will say is that the federal
government is very much concerned with
providing
the space
to
have those tools have the assets have
the personnel
so that enforcement actions can be
undertaken as quickly as possible
it is not for an elected representative
to put on a uniform put on a badge and
to go onto the streets and to do that
job we rely on our law enforcement
branch to do that work
the invocation of the emergencies act
is a tool
it's a new tool that we're using it's
never been used before in the country
now the good news is that
the framers of that statutory instrument
foresaw a predicament like the one that
we now find ourselves in to afford the
government some additional flexibility
so that law enforcement could for
example
declare certain
zones and areas that are adjacent to
critical infrastructure like borders
like our national symbols including
legislatures like war monuments so that
people who are participating in illegal
blockades which are clearly a breach of
the piece as a no-go zone now that is a
very tangible tool
there have been questions that have been
raised over the last number of days
about whether or not police have the
appropriate authorities be it in the
criminal code or in other provincial
legislation the declaration of the
emergencies act resolves that ambiguity
in addition to that the framers also
contemplated that there would be a need
to move with great rapidity
to get law enforcement
concrete tools like barriers like tow
trucks like other assets
in a way that is efficient so that they
can move forward with enforcement
operations where are appropriate
but i want to draw a bright line about
what the role of the government here is
and what the role of police is
and the role of police is to now utilize
those tools
in a way that is obviously respectful of
the charter in concert with provincial
and municipal authorities not in
conflict with them so that we can
restore
public order
no one wants to see another weekend like
the last three on wellington street and
i'm assured by my discussions with the
police that they fully appreciate that
and we now depend on them to do the job
um
you have not set out uh publicly what
zones are specifically designated as
no-go zones um if you could clarify if
that's something you're leaving to
police to do and why are you using
essentially language that's in the
terrorism act to describe the context
for enforcement measures you you
described uh in the declaration
political and ideological objectives of
protesters why are you using that
well that's uh that's actually a very
important question
and i think it cuts right to the core of
what we're confronted with in this
moment
there have been those who have tried to
characterize these illegal blockades
about vaccines and mandates and fatigue
with the pandemic that is not what is
driving
um this movement right now what is
driving this movement is a very small
organized group that is driven by an
ideology
to overthrow the government
through whatever means they may wish to
use
and yesterday's arrests
in coots
should
be a a cautionary tale
about what it is that we are precisely
dealing with here the seizure of a
significant number of illegal firearms
by a group that
is very committed to the cause
is something that we need to be very
sober about
now as absurd and as outlandish as the
claims may be of this group
one only has to survey the damage that
has been cost over caused over the last
number of weeks to our economy as a
result of the of of the interruption of
the flow of our supply chains but
equally here in ottawa
um
again like
you can't overstate what people who live
here in ottawa have had to go through
people who live in ottawa do not feel
safe right now they don't feel safe to
leave their homes they don't feel safe
to walk their streets they don't feel
safe to drop off their kids they don't
feel safe to go to work and they
certainly don't feel safe to go on
wellington street on the weekend and
that's just simply unacceptable
now the good news is that
the emergencies act contemplated this
kind of a moment and we've now reached
deep into the legislative toolbox um yes
carefully and deliberately to give those
additional uh resources to police that
they can act quickly and that is
certainly our hope that they do that
like just before we take the next
question of programming note the the
rules we have here we split time between
inside and outside so after this
question i will have to give a block of
time to people outside the room go ahead
thank you
gray from ctv questions for minister
mendocino yesterday after the prime
minister announced he wrote the press
conference that the emergency act was
brought into place i went down to
wellington and i talked to a bunch of
truckers they said hey the prime
minister just announced that you might
lose your insurance they could take your
truck they could freeze your bank
account pretty much everyone laughed in
my face said i don't care i'm not going
to change my mind we're not going to
move is it the government's position
that there is an expectation that force
will need to be used to remove at least
some of the truckers who were on
wellington and the other streets in
ottawa
short answer is we certainly hope not
and the uh invocation of the emergencies
act and the declaration
that follows with it sends a very
powerful message and hopefully a
deterrent to rational and fair-minded
individuals who may think that they're
just participating in a peaceful protest
but are actually now uh co-mingled with
something that is much more nefarious
and um you know for those that um you
know are seeking confrontation and or
violence
we rely on our law enforcement to use
their best judgment on how to resolve
that conflict of course
we want the illegal blockades to be
resolved peacefully
i mean that is obviously
the first
preference here and i know that uh
police services at every level uh
dispatch any number of tactics and and
techniques which are within their domain
of expertise to do just that and thus
far we have been very fortunate in that
there has not been any mass break of
outbreak of violence and that's the way
we want it to stay so to anybody who's
in the illegal blockades and who thinks
that this is um simply a peaceful
assembly
there are uh any number of clear signals
from the government um that now was the
time to go home
and of course um if people are not being
motivated and
one would think that the additional
powers that are introduced under the
emergencies act around seizing uh
proceeds and funds which is uh i think
an instrument that we'll be working very
closely with the banks and financial
institutions to operationalize
then here again we will depend on police
to do the job to do it responsibly to do
it within the parameters of the law and
the charter and to do it in a way that
is as peaceful as possible
you mentioned that there's an ideology
by the people who are here in ottawa to
overthrow the government and when you
combine that with the fact that we've
seen that there were a number of guns
seized by the rcmp and coutes is it also
your expectation that the trucks out on
wellington and around ottawa would have
guns in them as well
look
we
for an assessment of that have to rely
on law enforcement
i don't want to speculate about what may
or may not be
in possession of those who are
participating in the illegal blockades
and this gets back to what tondo was
asking earlier about who's responsible
for what
what elected representatives in
government um our responsible
governments are responsible for are to
give police the tools that are necessary
and yesterday's invocation of the
emergencies act is another tool
but in terms of operationalizing
those laws making them real on the
streets that's the job of the police
that's the job of those who put on the
uniform and the badge
and that's why we are
you know depending on them to restore
public safety in the most responsible
and professional manner that they can as
quickly and as peacefully as possible
okay we're going to turn to some calls
from outside the room now uh i'd like to
start with um melanie marquis la presse
followed by david thornton cbc melanie
your line should be opening
the floor is yours
yes
my question is directed at minister
point of clarification
you said it'll be moving from level
three to level two i just wanted to
clarify that that will be from the 28th
of february
moreover as of the why wait two weeks
before easing these restrictions
what's the scientific basis for that
two-week delay
to clarify yes it's the 28th of february
is a monday so it's the evening of uh
the sunday the 28th of february that
these changes will come into effect
secondly
the travel health notice is going from
level three to level two level three was
uh discouraging all
non-essential travel level two is
inviting canadians to exercise prudence
when they consider travel abroad
now you can break that down into two
ways
first to consider the situation the
state of affairs in their destination
country to get information about the
conditions they may find themselves in
based on the destination country
and also the conditions here back in
canada
second
consideration why the 28th of february
well obviously
the arrive can app needs to be updated
it needs to be properly programmed so
that everything could be properly rolled
out
okay
follow up
well if i've understood correctly
correct me if i'm wrong but this is more
of a planning issue out on the ground
rather than epidemiological
problems or difficulties
to do with this minister mendocino i'd
like to hear your reaction to
the fact that the ottawa chief of police
has stepped down did the government put
pressure on him to leave and do you
believe that this will enable us to turn
the page and open a new chapter as far
as this occupation of ottawa is
concerned response
absolutely not there was no pressure
brought to bear by the government
on the decision of the chief of police
in ottawa it's a decision of a personal
nature
from what i understand
and i wish to acknowledge uh chief
slowly's hard work over decades on the
front lines
of the police services
and law enforcement
now
our focus in the federal government is
to put
necessary resources at the disposal of
law enforcement
so that they can move ahead
with
an integrated operation to restore
good order and public safety in the
streets of ottawa
so that all ottawa residents can once
again find peace this is an unacceptable
state of affairs and that is our focus
going forward
uh david thornton cbc
minister mendocino you said it in french
there if i understood you correctly
you understand that chief slowly's
resignation was personal what do you
mean by that
my understanding is that this was a
resignation um i would just point out
that um to be clear that the federal
government had no role in the decision
um and that there are obviously you know
relationships that exist between chief
slowly and the ottawa police board that
are beyond the remit of the federal
government here um our focus is to
continue to give
the ottawa police service the ontario
provincial uh police and the rcmp all of
the resources that they need to restore
public order in
in the streets of ottawa
and um certainly the integrated central
command unit which has now been set up
does uh allow for um those tools to be
used in a very focused manner and i also
said in french that the situation here
in ottawa uh has been acceptable for
quite some time and it's our hope uh
that that public order will be restored
as quickly as possible
okay but
the chief of
uh police force in the capital city just
resigned
and you can forgive people
not only in ottawa but in the country
who feel like no one's leading the ship
here
so it doesn't really matter which
jurisdictional level of government is
speaking here i think people just want
clarity assurance can you tell us as
much as you know what you know about the
reason slowly resigned you said it's for
personal reasons i think you need to say
something more than that
no i just want to be clear
the decision was taken by chief slowly
completely independent
from the federal government
and
you know obviously those are questions
that will be put to chief slowly our
focus is to provide tools and resources
to the police so that they can do the
job of restoring public safety and that
is our focus and yesterday's declaration
of the emergencies act which was an
unprecedented moment in our country's
history history was another way in which
we could
make available to the disposal of the
ottawa police service the opp and the
rcmp
all of the things that they need
be it the ability to declare certain
zones as being prohibited from public
assembly
the ability to
commandeer assets uh like tow trucks
like barriers uh be it the ability to
dispatch rcmp officers to quickly
enforce municipal and provincial
legislation and yes as well uh
empowering banks and financial
institutions to put a stop to the flow
of proceeds that could advance the
illegal blockades as quickly as possible
all of which of course being within the
parameters of the law and the charter
and and we'll continue to do what we can
to give police those tools but we trust
them to restore public safety i mean to
your point
um yes you're right people don't want to
hear about jurisdiction they're not
interested in the in the in the nuances
what what i think people in ottawa
expect and have every right
to see happen is that public order will
be restored as soon as possible
okay let's turn now to marika walsh and
then bors poor um hello devoir
marika
hi there thanks very much for taking our
questions mr medicine my questions are
also for you
first on um your comments that nick that
i believe you said something along the
lines that nobody wants to see a repeat
of the last three weeks and the police
appreciate that so what
guarantees can you give ottawa residents
that things will change how quickly will
they change and how are you able to
ensure that there is not a repeat given
that it's tuesday we've lost today
there's no police chief
and there's a long weekend coming up and
we know more protesters will come
well i think that's a very fair question
and um all i can uh assure you and uh to
everybody who's watching is is that we
have uh conveyed
um the concerns of the community here
in ottawa uh and we've done it in a way
that is honest and direct
we have expressed the degree of anxiety
the concerns
and these are not just images on social
media you know there's a lot of traffic
over the course of the last three weeks
we're talking about people's lives and
so our job
in government is to ensure that law
enforcement uh understands and
appreciates uh exactly what the
community is feeling um the
conversations that we have we've had
particularly with my colleagues who work
in our government minister fortier and
mp nakvi uh have been uh extremely vocal
as has been all
the of the mps who are members of the
ncr caucus i want to be clear not only
in ottawa but also in the in the
gatineau
region
and our job is to make sure that that
police understand that anxiety
and from the exchanges that i've had
with with the commissioner
i believe that the rcmp
understand it
and i know that they're working day and
night uh to be sure that there is an
operation that will be put into effect
to restore public order it isn't easy
um you know the illegal blockade has now
become entrenched uh in the downtown
core
over the last three weeks
you see trucks on wellington street you
see other structures
um you know you see fireworks going off
you see barriers that have been toppled
i mean there's a there's a lot of work
that needs to be done but the point that
i would just make is that um you know
from my conversations with law
enforcement at the federal level
uh that they understand that challenge
and they're going to work day and night
to make sure that there isn't a repeat
thank you for that response and going to
another comment that i've heard
repeatedly from yourself and your
colleagues um
the government keeps pointing to the
situation in kutz as a justification or
one of the justifications for the
emergencies act being invoked but the
police were able to deal with
circumstances in kutz without the
emergencies act
so why is it that we need the
emergencies act if police in windsor and
in alberta were able to do their job and
to enforce public order and bring an end
to these blockades without the act in
place
well first i want to acknowledge the
exceptional work of the rcmp not only in
kutz
but in british columbia and in surrey
as well as in windsor
to restore public order and remove those
illegal blockades so that we can get
trade moving again i mean the
devastation that was caused uh as a
result of uh the obstructions uh to
those who are participating in the
illegal blockades is
is is is very deep and it needs to be
turned around but
as i explained yesterday
we can't take for granted the gains that
have been made
by law enforcement using existing
authorities and one of the
rationales for invoking the emergencies
act
is so that we can put into effect
additional tools to prevent another
illegal blockade from occurring and here
i'm thinking about
and i'm thinking about windsor in
particular and making sure that the
ambassador bridge remains open
putting our hands on the additional
barriers and tow trucks that are needed
uh to keep flow moving um as much as
possible so yes you're right
um there have there have been a number
of arrests and seizures that have been
made with pre-existing authorities but
we don't want it to occur again and
that's why
the measures which we have introduced
under the emergencies act which are
temporary they're targeted
they're geographically specific and they
are intended to operate in concert with
pre-existing provincial authorities
including where the rcmp are the police
of jurisdiction
um is a way in which we think
we can hold on to the gains that we have
made and keep the borders and the
bridges open and our national symbols
safe
uh
very patient person i know you also have
question period but let's start with the
question on the phone here
my first question is for minister du
clau i have the data
before my very eyes on the 29th of
january 35
of pcr tests at the border turned out to
be positive
so if my map is right
in an airplane if you look around you
one out of every 10 passengers is likely
to be infected with covert 19. so here's
what i'd like to know from you are you
throwing in the towel when it comes to
avoiding importing new variants into
canada that was your main rationale for
keeping the test in place response well
thank you for your question
indeed we need to continue to exercise
vigilance and prudence particularly so
at the border
and what we were waiting to see was a
drop in this positivity rate and based
on the most recent estimates that go
date back to late january well we waited
now till mid february and it is our
belief
that
uh
in the upcoming weeks even though it
will take some time for this data to
flow through we expect an improvement in
the situation that doesn't mean that
traveling will be without risk what it
means is that we'll continue to invite
canadians to exercise prudence to
continue to be smart when they think
about traveling abroad so moving from
level three to level two of this travel
health notice or travel advisory doesn't
mean that travel is without risk
henceforth or that when coming back to
canada you don't need to be careful also
so that's why we see the usefulness of
multiple layers of protection there's a
pre-departure layer
we still have that layer of protection
in place
even though the mandatory testing is no
longer responsible this will protect
canadians and those that they come rub
shoulders with over the course of their
travel follow-up question
for your colleague minister mendocino
the prime minister confirmed yesterday
that this emergencies act would not be
applied across canada but only where and
when necessary
and in collaboration with provincial and
territorial law enforcement so here's my
question will the federal government be
using
these measures under the emergency act
foisting them on provinces and
territories that aren't interested in it
like manitoba and alberta for example
well i think you've laid things out very
clearly here that is how the emergency
act will be rolled out
on the ground across canada
there are tools
under this act
that our novelty
now the most important thing and useful
thing to remain retained here is that
the tools under this
act will be used in court
for collaboration with law enforcement
in the provinces and territories
territorial and municipal uh
counterparts
ministers thank you mercy i know you
have to get to question period i'd also
if there's there's one reporter here who
might be able to squeeze something in
but i i realize you have to walk through
the trucks across the street to uh to uh
qp so thank you very much your time
messi mig watch
recording stopped
thank you the conference is now ended
please